good morning guys today is my last day
in texas before i go home
and i can't wait i haven't been
this long away from my bear and taika in
a long time so i miss him so much oh wow
it rained yesterday look at that
that's crazy
not that rates crazy but
we just don't see rain that much in like
the southwest you know which is
like california that all that oh this is
a hotel during the day it's beautiful
i love their like pink and green theme
yeah this is the hotel during the day
like the inside of the room
looks pretty nice it was a very comfy
bed very very comfy it was comfy enough
where i could just lay flat and not have
to roll around that much i think it was
tempur-pedic because i don't think it
makes any noise yeah it's memory foam
it was really nice it was a nice bed
i don't know what happened but i put on
my shorts like really hard yesterday
and this keeps freaking bleeding and
it's so annoying
because like i can just literally like
go like that and my shirt will pull on
my cuticle and they'll just bleed and
start gushing blood all over the place
look at this
like there's blood stains all over my
shorts i hope it doesn't ruin my shorts
i'll have to take it to jio's mom
because she knows all these crazy old
school tricks i spilled coffee and blood
one time and she was able to get it out
i don't know if she was like vinegar or
like steamed it or something but yeah i
need to find a way to plug it up i think
i just heard it
again it doesn't even hurt really it's
just annoying because blood just starts
gushing and yeah i don't even notice it
because it doesn't hurt at all i'm just
moving my hand around and then later i
look at all my stuff and they'll be like
drops of blood on my shoes i'm like on
my shirt i'm like oh my god that's so
bad
today i'm going to be checking out game
day barbell
it's a new gym in austin powerlifting
specific gym and it's opened by three
young cats plug the goat tim's i met tim
thibodeaux i've connected with pug
online back and forth but i don't know
who the third owner is but it's really
inspiring
because these three dudes
usually people that open gems in the
fitness space they have a pretty big
following you know it's almost like
there's a couple of prerequisites that
you do and it almost feels like okay
cool this is like a lateral transfer in
my career that i should be doing
but these young cats um they're smaller
because they're very niche into like the
very like high level legit power lifting
space
and they just teamed up
and they have dope branding and they
created a really really cool gym and so
it's really inspiring to see
like young cats do things you know just
be brave have the courage team up with
their friends if they can't do it
themselves and just do whatever it takes
to get it done to achieve their goals so
i'm gonna be over there checking them
out um and we had an official
announcement so hopefully you guys been
following me on instagram park quan and
our barber brigade instagram brigade
because we're gonna be posting stories
like crazy and hopefully there's uh
a bunch of you that uh you guys there
and then we could say what's up
unfortunately i'm not going to lift
because i have to jump on a flight right
after so i didn't want to get all sweaty
and stuff i would have loved to train
with everyone
but if people are lifting
you know i'm the best hype man in the
world
if you guys have seen that clip of me
yelling at geo oh yeah for you guys too
yesterday at terry black's since it's
such a legendary place i bought two hats
there they just look cool too terry
black's barbecue and this is like a
olive green looks pretty cool
and then
i got this one this one was kind of like
looks like a dad hat but i don't know if
it really is i don't even try it on to
be honest but
this one's more like a gray
but just looks like old school you know
so i liked it
not too sure what happened but
i have a pretty bad headache and only
on this side
like when i don't have my normal routine
and you guys know i'm a caffeine fiend
maybe because i didn't take pre-workout
for a couple of days i didn't train or i
didn't have my cup of coffee like
my body is such like clockwork if i
don't hit caffeine exp like at that
exact same time every day almost
guaranteed 30 minutes later i'm gonna
have a headache like i think i usually
have caffeine in the morning like around
five or six when i train
and if i don't train i need to get
coffee in it at that time and since i
slept in a little bit maybe i slept past
it i don't know
but
oh i have a headache and i hate that
because i have to do a podcast i don't
want to be doing a podcast like this
one
little pointer for you guys that are
going to be traveling these are almost
like the three most important things i
like to keep on my body
when i'm traveling it's very very small
but
it makes traveling
so good if these are issues you guys
deal with so number one
i always have a little bit of um like a
headache medicine either this or tylenol
because you just never know when you
might have a headache and when you have
like a little headache like that it can
totally ruin a trip like i've been in
hawaii where everything is beautiful the
food is beautiful it's so relaxing but
for some reason i just have this crazy
migraine and you can't even enjoy any of
it you know what the sun's shining on
you and you're like oh it hurts and you
don't want to do that so i always keep
that
the next thing is
some allergy
medicine if you're like me um and you're
allergic to cats honestly there's times
where i've been in a room
where all those in my eyes start
watering my nose is stuffed up but once
again i'm in like this formation and
it's just so bad and it ruins everything
so i do take this because i don't think
i'm really allergic to anything else but
sometimes there is like crazy pollen
attacks and the last thing i want is to
be stuffy nose and all that so
i always have these two
and then also
chapstick
like the the one of the worst things is
when you're traveling and like
everything's fine like pain like big
pains i can deal with you know like
someone sucked me in the arm
or like [ __ ] broke my toe or
something i can deal with but just
little annoying things where your lips
are all just cracking and you just keep
licking them like it's like a natural
response you know when your lips feel
dry you naturally lick them but then
it's worse because the saliva dries out
even more once it hits the sun and it
gets worse and where it starts bleeding
then you eat like a hot soup and then
your lips are hot i mean uh are in pain
and then nothing tastes good and just
constantly licking your lips and your
lips get all inflamed and now you can't
take any cool pictures from memories
these are just three really small things
and i think i should add a couple
band-aids to the mix because
it's bleeding again
so this is what the uh public
bathroom looks like remember that
hallway from yesterday
i don't know how to use this wall
you come in from this line right that's
the hotel hallway
and then you come in here
and there's a shower still cool pink and
green theme
and then um
there's not a toilet
and all the rooms on this floor we share
but i first look like i got my little
hygiene bag over there
and yeah those three things
the allergy headache and chapstick i
don't keep them there because that i
usually put in my um
my check-in but those we do i like to
keep on like my personal bag like my
backpack because you never know when
those [ __ ] hit so i was in your
check-in and it happens on the plane
but and yeah i'm like a five-hour flight
not a good time
going through the streets of austin
right now
looking for a coffee place i feel like
it wouldn't be too hard to find that's
the most austin thing ever
just people on bird scooter yeah people
on little bird scooters everyone was on
one last night yeah i saw like a little
grass hill and there's like 20 of them
parked there
it's really nice we got one already yeah
just right here i told you it's illegal
to not have one every other source
that's the most austin thing ever and i
bet you they have like all the the what
is it drip french drip poor cold brew
nitro
they don't have just coffee it's you
can't so is it illegal for me to get
just a regular coffee do you have to get
some fancy ass like i think it's weird
if you just walk into any coffee shop
and can i get a coffee like with
everything's coffee like what kind
all right that's true
i'm usually not a big fan of humidity
but in the spring
it's really nice because it really
brings out it feels good the scents like
you could smell the trees the concrete
like the flowers
and like the the wind has like a nice
touch to it like it's like uh like it's
caressing you it does feel like tropical
yeah it feels tropical it's like during
the spring actually feels really good
no i'm not gonna get energy drink you're
gonna get energy drink
let's see
dang look at their coffee selection
this is just our bottled one
and canned one bold and smooth super
brew caffeine and elephanine
then this is next level dude
what happened
what
this
so one thing that austin's known for now
is who food no who
who who
joe rogan
you got kill cliffs oh it's jalapenos
yeah they do right where is it oh yes
there's a signature well there's izzy's
and then the flaming gel
are you gonna get one you have to all
right it's like this wait is that
alcoholic though no no it's uh
uh okay well you try your tummy okay i
don't know if i'm i'm i want jalapeno in
the liquid form is
yeah you have to he's a new president in
town
go through that
all right so yeah they got cbd infused
they got this is cbd views too it says
cbd i mean they're just trying to put
cbd in the front of it
right oh yeah 20 milligrams cbd wow
that's so cool well you got to be
careful what you get you might get too
relaxed
so i might i'm about to apologize i
don't want to be that relaxed
let's see
so
i think that was more of a bodega than
like a coffee coffee shop i saw coffee
here completely bought me a tea i was
like yeah i know
i think maybe their kitchen wasn't open
maybe the coffee is like vietnamese
coffee with their bun me
um but i still got a cool coffee i got
that performance one with lp ending in
it which is cool because that helps the
focus it's the same thing we put in our
pre-workout so maybe i'm gonna be ham on
the podcast
i know it's like an extra cookie it's
like usually i know this is extra
super cold brew this is like the coffee
version of pre-workout
maybe we'll bang out this podcast and be
like
[Laughter]
so if i had to choose to live between
austin and houston
so far and this is really weird
just because i like hills so you see how
the street goes up and down you can't
really see the grade actually
on camera as well but just because
there's hills i like austin more
i'm a big fan of like not just flat land
i don't know that
even though like flat land and it's
super expansive yeah it's you would
think it doesn't give me claustrophobia
but when everything's the same it kind
of gives me claustrophobia it kind of
gets boring yeah then this kind of feels
like a city yeah where it's like i also
i like houston a lot yeah um
but i really love like she like that
where it's like just like random things
local butcher shop you know yeah uh i'm
sure they have that in houston but it's
like every single spot here it's very
like unique like mom and pop like weird
yeah like the way they like to describe
it uh and it keeps giving me like those
uh it keeps talking about where it's
like it feels like portland yeah um
it's just like super cool where it's
just like all these like restaurants
it's very like nice clean yeah uh
and
see look at this scooters dude that's
austin right there scooters yeah but la
has like scooters that are just
everywhere i know that's true too
aha there it is
i see the sign
game day barbell
let's see
where do we go
it says on your right 250 feet oh is
that dead
right down there
oh
dad is huge
damn
that's dope are you guys going to fill
the rest of this place up with more
equipment so uh low key in the next
month where uh on that on that side over
there we have six comma wrecks yeah
we're getting another six so wow it's
gonna be uh twelve karma rex on that
side
doubling the dumbbell section there's
actually a gym nearby that's selling
like a lot of equipment is buy it all up
oh i mean yeah unfortunately they're
kind of shut down yeah which kind of
stuff yeah we're buying a lot of their
stuff so that's dope too much
basically
how big is this space
15 000 square feet holy [ __ ] to work
with man hey what's up tim what's up
dude like seven years i know how are you
how are you
all right so i just found out none of
these three are from austin texas you're
from where new jersey oh you're from
where pennsylvania and then you're from
where dc so how did you guys end up
here opening a gym together social media
yeah social media yeah
social media what do you mean austin's
the social media hotspot of the world i
would say well i would i would say like
everyone's flocking here now so oh
i guess like the social media hub yeah
so did you guys literally look at a map
and go where should we it could be
anywhere it wasn't like well no we had
come down here but you know what's
ironic is between the three of us and
our home states i feel like personally
the power lifting gyms are super
developed right yeah and then we come
down here we visit we're like oh austin
it's in texas
uh you know home state of powerlifting
they must have excellent powerful trips
and they do but um they're incredibly
small like the ones that we've seen
all under 10k square feet and where i'm
from there's like four or five gyms all
over 30 000 so they're holy massive
facilities yeah
um and we came down here and we're
thinking no usa apl meets
no massive parallel gyms this is kind of
our time to shine
so it's very strategic yeah damn that's
dope man yeah i mean guys are smart if
we're gonna grow the sport of
powerlifting we need to
go where powerlifting is and
i guess
like reignite it yeah yeah yeah
the actual story of how we came together
is really interesting because tim was
streaming on twitch
and
he was saying oh i you know i want to
start a gym yeah and richard and i like
i you know coach him in powerlifting we
got to talking we're like we should we
should go in on that with tim so we got
him on a zoom call and before we knew it
the three of us were opening a gym
together that's crazy that's dope man
was like the most automatic yes that
we've ever heard
i've seen him on youtube for the last
like like alongside you yeah last 10
years been watching them on youtube yeah
and then joe and i have obviously been
like coach athletic relationship for the
last
and then right four years
idea popped up we were all just like
yeah like automatically we've seen each
other's work ethic the things we've done
online like we just want to work just
have mutual respect and you're like
let's [ __ ] do it yeah honestly that's
dope man
we just finished filming and now we're
getting lunch and we're eating a
cabo bob's didn't know quite what it was
but now that i saw those burritos i'm
really happy because i'm freaking
starving and then i wanted something
that was like
fulfilling are you found burritos i love
burritos me too i hate
i really like chipotle but chipotle
always [ __ ] up my stomachs
[Music]
not enough time to get copyrighted
but they're so good and i like i don't
have access to other like good burritos
like that yeah i mean obviously we're in
l.a i do but like i don't go yeah um
so i'm really excited for this my
favorite burritos are wet burritos
so i hope they have something like we
eat with the knife and fork and it's
like that
yeah cause it's almost like eating a
lasagna like a big fat with a lot of
meat in the middle it's like it already
added hella sauce on top
so what do you recommend to get here
what's their like go-to [ __ ] yeah get
the burrito get the cilantro
tomatillo tortilla
where are you feeling bold feeling
healthy you get bowl i'm not feeling
healthy i get a burrito i'm trying to
say something
okay
so what are they known for here the
brisket and the fish okay
with the crispy fish so the tortillas
are like different flavors so it's not
just like a buttermilk tortilla they
hand make their own they're like
customizable
and they can combine two different
flavors cilantro and chili and then make
one tortilla
that's crazy get the crispy fish
i trust them i like your enthusiasm so
i'm gonna trust you appreciate it
[Music]
um can i have
a brisket
all right so i got the fish tacos
the fish tacos look really good he told
me to get beef and fish together
but i was like i
but i do like their handmade like
tortillas though
how is it
yeah
so i did everything i got grilled onions
in here that's the best tortilla this
one
is
just went through uh tsa easy breezy
because we got an email that uh we
should show up three
three hours early before our flight
because the security lines are hella
long apparently a lot of people are
flying in and out of austin
not to mention i think this is an older
airport so this is it just doesn't have
the infrastructure for it so me and the
dm were like you know we should probably
just show up earlier so instead of
showing up three hours earlier we showed
up five hours later here which i'm very
happy for because not to wait in line
for very long the line already started
to loop though so we're through it now i
gotta find my date about date 26
seeing that's like 18 19.
it should be going this way
i do have a long time now so i'm gonna
see if i can get into a lounge somehow
that'd be
cool a bad map
all right cool so we found a lounge and
i reconnected with nadine so if you're
hanging out for i need to have like five
hours how about you four four hours this
is a good place to work grab some snacks
and drinks you want to find like a show
place to kick it yeah all right let's go
so yeah lounges are cool because you get
to hang out especially when you're on an
international flight
where um
you're expected to show up by two to
three hours early anyways oh look at
that orange water
you like refreshments drinks
a lot of these like credit cards now
they have um these really cool rewards
so yeah you get to come hang out
sometimes i just like lay on the floor
take a nap but it's really quiet here
get some work done got plugs and stuff
this is cool
found a spot
it's packed everywhere there's usually
another side too
oh yeah oh yeah that's nice look at that
there you go hang out outside
except you can't go to the store but
that's nice
this feels nice we found a little
outdoor spot
i'm sitting on these super little lounge
chairs which is why it looks like i'm
just like
laying like this
but this one's pretty cool i might
actually try to put
like two of these chairs together
so i'm gonna create like a little bed
and take a nap i'm pretty tired
it feels crazy like taiwan here because
it's like humid but it's still windy
you smell like all the nice smells from
the plants
it's pretty peaceful is that a bird
it is
what is all that dude dude they have
hella good food
dang
i won't be one of these [ __ ] four
people downstairs you know
that's stupid this is your first time in
the lounge
uh second night what was the first time
first time i think it was with brad
when we're going to europe
oh he had uh like one of those amx
platinum or gold cards something
or was he flying first class huh was he
flying first class he was playing first
test oh yeah if you get first class you
you automatically get lounge access too
yeah as [ __ ] because i wasn't playing
because it was like seven thousand
dollars to uh upgrade oh yeah and it was
like
uh it was to the uk yeah it was horrible
i think maybe it was to australia
oh okay yeah and that's where we we uh
we're in the airplane for like stuck in
hawaii yeah for like i think like three
four days yeah so i had to sit next to
two cramped like big-ass bodybuilders
i would say about 16 hours a day
yeah not moving yeah he's huge dude like
six three two sixty and then he was like
he felt bad it was like [ __ ] swift
spots yeah i switched maybe to the the
first class like
three minutes in the deep uh detain us
and then the in the actual like terminal
where you sit yeah it it wasn't the
seats that can like raise the arm yeah
you're cooling down you're like laying
on the floor before
so a lot of you guys might be wondering
why there's so many different color
cards like you've seen gold got a
platinum like this one
and usually it's because of the benefits
so what's cool about having one of these
cards because there is like an annual
membership
it has benefits that can get you into
lounges so if you travel a lot it's
super worth it because you know to have
membership to one of these lounges it
could be anywhere from 300 bucks to a
thousand dollars a year
and there's uh different types of lounge
groups so to get all of them you might
even need to spend like two or three
grand a year versus if you have one of
these cool platinum carts you could just
spend uh four or five hundred bucks
on the card membership and they'll get
you access into all these lounges on top
of that a lot of the ones that you pay
you get really uh good points reward
system so for example
like all the purchases that you make
like usually typically like for me just
buying gas or buying groceries at the
end of the year because of all the
points i'll get a couple of free flights
throughout the year so that's the reason
why you know when you look at like these
credit cards where they're always
sending these promotions they have
points they have different benefits so
that's why you really want to look into
i know in the beginning when you open
those free credit card things and you're
like what's up with all this fine print
is so confusing if you really read into
it it's actually quite helpful
especially for times like this but i
need a place to chill and it's super
quiet i got plugs i can even take a nap
some of them even have showers and stuff
so very very helpful
all right so we've been sitting here
hanging out working a little bit and now
i'm about to board the plane so i try to
like wait till the last minute to eat
because i know if i eat too early i'm
gonna get hungry anyways because i'm a
fat ass right now
but anyways i went over to the uh
cafeteria section and i made
my own concoction so all these are
separate ingredients i found a cilantro
rice thing i put that at the bottom then
i found a braised chicken thing and i
put braised chicken over then i went
over to the soups and then they had a
roasted red pepper gouda soup
so i put that over the chicken and then
i found some sour cream so i put it on
top of that so i just made my own like
little braised chicken
stew bowl look at that
it came out pretty good huh and i have a
whole pile of chicken on there there's
probably like 50 grams of protein in
here
that's really good
good yeah
it's creamy tomatoey
limey rice chicken
if i wasn't such a fat ass and i just
ate just the chicken and the rice it'd
actually be pretty
macro friendly
but
not on die right now so
dude
look how packed this airport is
i mean given not everyone is in the seat
because it's probably uncomfortable to
sit side by side with everyone but
it is packed
note to self
never fly out of austin again
walk into my gate now and as you can see
i'm alone
i'm not with the dean because nadeem is
flying directly back to la i'm flying
back to vegas you see my bare enticing
which i'm very excited because i haven't
been away from them for this long in a
long long time i think i was gone friday
saturday sunday
monday four days
that's a long time especially now that
taika speaks and stuff
i think it's easier to live when it was
like a little baby as a dad because you
don't have that big of a connection
right because you guys can't talk to
each other yet and i think moms are
closer
but
now that i could talk to him
last night i was facetiming geo like a
face timer and her phone was all dark
because she picked it up in the middle
of the night at like 9 30
and i was like hey babe i miss you
and then uh gio was like
i miss you too
and then out from the back i get tiger
going do you miss me peppa i was like oh
a couple misses you two and then so he
jumped over and then jill's like damn
that you woke them up you know kids are
really hard to put to sleep so we didn't
want to hype them up but it ended up
being a really fun phone party anyways
so
yeah i'm really excited to see them
just landed
and
this airport
tripped me out
because i was slept like a good three
hours on the flight which is cool i
slept the whole way through
and so like in my mind i'm so used to
the routine right so
when i got off the plane
i thought i was at lax because i'm so
used to flying to lax vegas it has been
my home for the last year but it's still
new in my life
so i got off
um the terminal and i started seeing
slot machines and stuff and i'm like
what in the world why is your slot
machine at lax and i'm like oh no no no
lax is not my own
vegas is my home i'm at mccarran airport
i'm like oh my god i'm so out of it
that was crazy now i'm gonna get my
luggage
and i'm finally gonna go home
i see them
baby
i saw your car
hey there's a monkey cheeto in there
lord you're supposed to be sleepy
you big cutie guy
but doesn't it
oh that's so cute
hey monkey cheater
that's cutie pies
where's spider-man going
cute
hey that's my side
you big cuny
here you go you little bowls of brains
that's his side that's where he's been
sleeping that's his side now huh isn't
that your side yes that's cuny taki
always takes care of mama protects mom
when papa's gone
but the only way we sleep though is like
this
and now we're both on top of this
excuse me never watch this movie oh that
one that's his new favorite movie i
actually have never watched it i gotta
watch it with you
you like it i gotta watch it with you
monkey
that's kiwi pie
all right guys now that i'm home i'm
gonna get ready for bed
brush my teeth take a shower
wash all the travel off
and get ready to crush this week and i
hope you guys had a great time following
me go through houston austin and all
that and then i'm back home and i'll see
you guys tomorrow good night